this video is sponsored by epal.gg more
about it later in the video
Summer's pretty much over and I'm sure
everyone's made a verdict on what their
best summer anime is as a season I think
this was one of the more underrated ones
in recent Years yet we don't have a lot
of super mainstream hits but that
doesn't mean there's nothing to be
excited for in retrospect today we'll be
talking about what I think are some of
the best fights the season has to offer
after all what better way to start
saying goodbye to a surprisingly fun
season than with that stuff that you
guys all enjoy action Clips fight
summaries and more
to kick things off we have engaged
kisses first episode fight
ing things off on the right track here I
think coming into the season engage kiss
is one of the shows I was very excited
about since it takes a lot of the check
boxes for these knee shits that I also
enjoy the vn-like feel a combination of
comedy romance and action as well as
attractive character designs I'd also
say that the show started off on the
right foot for battle enthusiasts with
this fight right here yes things get
much wider later but for this video I'd
like to start off featuring something
simple that can make a good first
impression as early as the first episode
you can already see that this anime is
great in terms of visuals and fight
Direction the actions Fast and Furious
and the Bantam mitscuffer only serves to
enhance the moment I just love seeing
some of my liked tropes in action at the
moment I know this Show's a keeper
engage kiss isn't the show that will
blow everyone away but in terms of
casual entertainment it hits the right
notes for me came after buying the waifu
bait coming out of the Season feeling
super satisfied
Heinz versus gojin is up next
it's been a while since Overlord has
reached a level of hype it seems such as
the sad fate of a show that spanned
multiple Seasons already but for us
loyal fans who've stayed throughout
here's a reward for everyone an
excellent battle that pits our
Unstoppable irons against the warrior
king go gym from an outsider's
perspective The Duel does look a little
bit like a mismatch gojin simply Towers
over everyone's favorite skeleton guy
and the fight goes exactly as you'd
expect iron surprisingly takes a bit of
a thrashing at first but we all know
that the comeback is coming and easily
turns the tables and shows everyone that
he hasn't lost a step he systematically
dismantles gojin until the proud King
has been laid bare or to set up that
final blow a stab that seems so simple
yet powerful the results should be no
shock to fans of Overlord but seeing
irons assert dominance and flex on his
opponent in such a manner never gets old
this may not be the most brutal irons
win but it's got a place amongst the
best fights of Summer 2022
now that's one amazing fight isn't it we
do have a lot more but if you were to
ask me exciting anime fighter better
enjoyed with a companion that's what
today's sponsor is all about epal.gg is
your go-to site if you're feeling lonely
and you just want to have someone to
talk to I know several anime fans share
that sentiment of wanting someone to be
friends with or to talk anime and gaming
about and that's what today's sponsor is
here to answer paypal.gg is a social
networking site aimed to save those
needs of yours whether it be coaching
that you need for games and always
trustworthy teammate to help you climb
the ranks of the gaming world or just a
crying shoulder to support you when
you're feeling down from losing five
games in a row e-pal.gg will find you
the perfect match while the site caters
mostly to gaming anime fans can also
join in on the fun too after all
everyone desires that one companion to
share your passions with right you can
check out the website in the link below
make an account and start meeting
different people to join you on your
journey check out epal.gg now
speaking of adaptations with so many
seasons how about something cool from
dunmachi
[Music]
one of the most
sin down Machi Bell finally gets a
chance to Showcase his growth and
defeats Moss huge in this confrontation
and like the irons Fight This Is A True
Underdog battle as well has got to
contend with a giant monster that's
pretty much Superior to him in every
conceivable way this Moss huge also
comes with enhanced intelligence and
even with all his efforts Belle finds
himself in the defensive against an
Unstoppable Onslaught however the
brightest stars shine in the darkest
moments and this might as well be one of
the landmark episodes of Dan mighty's
latest season this sets the stage for
Belle to reveal his new technique
coating his dagger with fire in a scene
that's so well put together the
presentation to the sound and the
resulting attacks is something that
would have caused people to erupt in
Applause in a theater setting donomachi
has had an up and down Journey as the
seasons go by but this latest season has
some of the best fights I've seen lately
the animation and voice acting is as
good as ever and seeing Belle unleash
this new skill game me goosebumps
Jolene versus Westwood ought to give
this JoJo season some spunk
so the second half really up the ante
with these fights as the story starts
heating up while it's nice to have the
anime give the spotlight to the side
characters isn't it about time for
Jolene to take center stage now and boy
could she make the most out of it the
West would fight may not have had too
much hype coming into it but as The
Clash does go on it becomes more and
more immersive this battle does more
than its fair share of showing jolene's
growth and her even stronger result for
victory and survival it's a good old
one-on-one Showdown and we get to see
jolene's pulling out from the bag of
tricks to overcome what seemed to be an
uphill battle I don't think Stone ocean
will rank too high on people's Power
Rankings due to its Simplicity we've got
to give some props to how well Jolene
manages to utilize it in combination
with her own physical skills
us
Ruby's here to join the fun too
[Music]
ice queen damn isn't something that
takes a while to become good I've
enjoyed it as early as the first few
episodes it may have lacked stuff that
made the original Ruby special but it
had made up for it with a lot of the
genuine anime feel that I really liked
however with the latter episodes I mean
let's just say that the fight scenes
have been well pushed to another level
take this fight for example to say that
the fight choreography is insane is an
understatement and the whole sequence of
defeating nightmare Blake is a Trope
that I won't ever get tired of when
Blake got free and the insert song
starts playing Goosebumps man the inset
song just made the scene so much more
hype I can't wait for the full version
I'm not so sure how World ice queen dim
is doing in terms of getting new people
into the franchise as far as I'm
concerned it's the perfect entry point
for people who just can't do without the
anime aesthetic it's got everything
people love about anime right there
[Applause]
how can we talk about signature fights
this summer season without going over
Luffy versus kaido
[Music]
it's one of the most anticipated battles
of all time and it didn't disappoint not
even one bit even I as a massive fan
don't know what my favorite part of the
fight is I mean could it be when Luffy
infuses himself with conqueror haki and
punches kaido so hard the old opening
starts playing I mean it certainly is a
strong candidate and I'm sure that even
lapsed fans of One Piece would find a
reason to come back and share tears at
such an epic moment this lengthy fight
had everything drama moments that make
you go wow and if you're in any way
interested in one piece and you should
be by the way this is history being made
something to remember for the ages
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
another great fight to wrap things up is
chisato versus majima's final Jew
there are so many things to like about
licorice recoil a strong candidate for
anime of the Season people loved it for
the Dynamics between characters and the
action the latter which looks like
something straight out of Hollywood
Blockbusters in its frantic fervor
there's never a dull moment in the show
and that carries on all the way until
the final battle hitting chisato and
majima against each other once and for
all it's a very good gunfight and
there's more than just a fast-paced eye
pleaser as it's also integrated with the
conclusion to their character arcs and
philosophies the break and the pseudo
family banter really added a dimension
to their relationship and I love how as
soon as they're done talking it's back
to the action in full swing with
everything on the line licorice recoil
is more than its pretty animation for
its fight scenes way more than that but
if you're the type who can't get enough
of sequences like this and are tired of
all the overloaded special effects for
magical powers in fantasy anime licorice
record is a healthy recommendation
last but not least we have humans versus
shadows in summertime render
time Brenda has been a roller coaster of
emotions I've watched a lot of time Loop
shows but rarely does it hit as hard as
this I guess it has to do with how
physical and brutal the deaths are and
it really drives home the idea that the
stakes are so high hey they even did the
thing where the protagonist doesn't have
infinite continues with how much of an
underdog Humanity has been presented
against shadows in the Dozen episodes
before this seeing an all-out battle
between Shin face team and the invading
Shadows is a treat despite being
underdogs the group United manages to
put up a fight and even get a win over
the invading Army picking up an unlikely
Ally along the way the fighting's as
intense as always and it has a lot of
suspenseful moments too many close calls
for Comfort that's what really kept me
watching the whole moment is as
unpredictable as you can get but hey
that's pretty much the trademark of the
show since then right it keeps you
guessing before violently pulling the
plug and giving you even more questions
and anticipation I really love
summertime render and what it's not
exactly a show where the fighting is the
main appeal it sure plays an extremely
big role and I'm all for it and there
are some more amazing fights in the
series like pretty much everything
involving the forearm Shadow towards the
end game
[Applause]
and that's got to do it for my favorite
fights this summer 2022. now if you
enjoyed this video once again leave a
like share it with your friends don't
forget to subscribe and don't forget to
check out epal.gg links in the
description once again thank you for
watching and I hope to see you again
till next time
[Music]